"Smelly cat, smelly cat
What are they feeding you?"
That's right! We're learning this week with the famous song "Smelly Cat" by Phoebe on Friends.
Every single week, we help learners like you to understand fast-speaking natives
So, if that sounds like something
you would like to be able to do,
then be sure to hit that Subscribe button
and the red bell down below
so you don't miss a single one of our new lessons.
Are you enjoying learning with Smelly Cat?
Well, let us know and show our channel some support
by hitting that Like button down below.
Do you get frustrated when you can't understand
fast-speaking natives?
Well, you are not alone.
That is why we created this FREE 3-Part Mini-Course
that will help you to learn
to understand fast-speaking natives.
You can learn more by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
All right, before we test everything that
you have learned in this lesson,
I wanted to let you know that if
you liked learning with Smelly Cat,
you're absolutely going to
love this lesson that we teach you
with the song "I'll Be There For You",
which is the theme song from Friends.
You can find that by clicking up here
or down in the description below.
I hope you understood that whole
scene a lot better the second time around.
Be sure to hit Subscribe so you
can get every one of our newest lessons.
Also, check out that mini course I told you about.
And, learning with music is absolutely
one of the best ways to improve your pronunciation
and English vocabulary, so check out this playlist
of lessons teaching you with songs in English.
Also, check out this other video
that I think you'll really like.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!